marvel's what-if is all about
reimagining the mcu as we know it
episode one saw peggy carter become the
world's first super soldier instead of
steve rogers while episode two saw
t'challa a star-lord instead of peter
quill however for episode 3 it's more
than just a simple substitution the
story revolves around the avengers and
nick fury's quest to bring the group
together simply put the question we're
meant to ask ourselves in this episode
is what if the avengers never happened
wow so serious
the episode primarily focuses on how the
avengers are picked off one by one even
the strongest and seemingly immortal
ones get their tails handed to them in
one shocking death after the next first
tony stark is killed by natasha romanov
accidentally then clint barton
inadvertently takes out thor with the
archer's death following in a prison
cell shortly after the hulk is next to
meet his end in a rather gruesome death
and sadly we say goodbye to natasha
again as she's the last of the group to
bite the bullet for most of the episode
we wonder who is the person behind these
attacks and while they weren't exactly
hiding in plain sight they were right in
front of us the whole time what a
fascinating choice of words
natasha figures out the mysterious
killer after logging into some shield
files at a public library she realizes
that hope van dyne had also logged into
the system despite being dead for two
years after hearing natasha screaming to
him on the phone that is all about hope
nick fury heads to the wasps gravesite
where he's met by her father hank pym
looking absolutely haggard hank is
revealed as a killer of all five
avengers we then get a small flashback
of the deaths of the would-be avengers
where we see tiny little hank in his
ant-man outfit killing all of the
would-be superheroes so the fact that we
couldn't see the killer the whole time
should have been a dead giveaway it
turns out hank is exacting revenge on
shield for the death of his daughter who
fury explains died outside of ukraine
during a mission for the agency hank
blames shield for her death and decides
the appropriate revenge is killing five
people wanting fury to see everything
he's worked for regarding the avengers
die you never cared about hope i don't
give a damn about any of them in a
shocking twist no one could see coming
fury takes down the man who killed five
avengers with the help of loki the god
of mischief has already come to earth
for vengeance after learning of thor's
death but fury convinces him to give him
more time to find the killer with the
help of loki's magic fury has the upper
hand over hank and the latter is
eventually taken into custody here is
where we get to imagine what would
happen in the mcu if hank killed five of
the six avengers after fury tells loki
to go back where he came from the
trickster reveals he wants to extend his
stay on midgard with a mischievous grin
we then see loki give a speech to the
united nations in new york city where he
appears to have become the new leader of
earth now it's time for a new group of
heroes to assemble to take down loki who
was living out the life he only could
have dreamed of in another reality
the avengers fell before they had a
chance to rise
may they rest in peace they can
but we won't
as you watch the episode and the poor
avengers get picked off one by one you
might wonder where captain america was
well he was still doing time as a
capsicle under the ice fury also puts a
call out on his favorite pager while
dusting the snow off of cap's frozen
shield at the end of the episode captain
marvel pops in ready for battle so we
now have a team of two avengers who will
take on loki as he rules the world with
a loyal army of asgardians behind him in
this reality things are vastly different
than we know them from the infinity saga
timeline knocking out natasha thor the
hulk iron man and hawkeye means only a
few super people and worthy shield
agents are left based on this timeline
and the story of hope van dyne and hank
pym we can assume that scott lang is
just a regular old criminal and not
ant-man the winter soldier is still out
there somewhere but he likely won't be
recruited into a new avenger team
spider-man in this universe isn't around
yet and the guardians of the galaxy have
yet to be formed t'challa also hasn't
taken on the mantle of black panther
which means that slim pickings for fury
it looks like loki might have a nice run
as ruler of midgard for quite some time
but captain marvel should be a worthy
adversary of the trickster together with
steve rogers the pair might be able to
take him down
but only if fury can find them some
strong sidekicks this episode really has
us wondering what it will take for the
watcher to get involved if killing 5
avengers doesn't encourage him to step
in what will
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you